como evitar um jogador novo na bola
isso não dá busca eo pintado não pára só
explique muito champagne para mim
[Música]
agora você só pra ela
basta aprender o que tem mais esta caixa
cobra uma camisola precisa de roupa
miguel monteiro então festa essa roupa e
sem rejeição de emergência miguel é uma
chefe do espaço miguel tem alguma chance
do espaço então por que comprar perto
não comprei isso subir à liga o bairro
miguel 05 miguel é filha precisa de ter
uma chefe que não só o próprio é melhor
que ficar chega de share
as coisas dela uma toalha edson
francisco 016 miguel meu cabelo não é
pra capar miguel pinho caixa
isto é sério porque o miguel vai morrer
mais uma vez um cinto miguel diz que
miguel como é que está a jogar mesmo sem
interdição do campo já conhece o jogo
muito bem a nova arma miguel nunca vista
em um shopping com essa arma
só quem não fique com isto para não tem
mais nada na caixa
saber jogar em todas as secções em todas
não cair agora isso não esse fogo não se
brinca puto
miguel sai brinca miguel miguel de
morrer e 8 mil
[Música]
ninguém em quem o ataque super supremo
do gelo
[Música]
meu deus olha aí tudo para comprar uma
caixa com pessoal fique em junho o ipc s
subiu ao perceber que foi negado